( intro music )
( applause )
Pan Conrad: We are on Mars!
So, I'm going to go way back
and to facilitate that
I've provided you
with my way back machine...
a blank slate.
Because I want to take you
so far back,
we don't have a picture
of that.
About 4.6 billion years ago,
when the Universe was just
a little more than
half as old as it is now,
the Solar System formed.
And it was
a supreme act of violence.
The sun was in the center,
big hunks of rock were made
from little hunks of rock,
which were made from
little tiny grains.
How everything came together
was a function
of the chemistry
of the materials.
And the chemistry
of the materials changed
as a function
of the relationships
between all these
little bits of stuff.
When the bits of stuff became
bigger bits of stuff,
and we had big rocks
and then the big rocks became
really big rocks and they
glommed into each other,
we started getting these
protoplanets.
And these big hunks of rock
that we call 'planetesimals'
generated
so much heat and pressure,
by the time you got
sufficient mass
that you got a lot of melting
and recrystallization
and before you knew it,
well not before you knew it,
it did take
till 4.6 billion years ago.
We got something that was
an amalgamated planet
and that is
the infancy of the Earth.
That is the infancy of
all the planets
and depending upon
where they sit
with respect
to their central star
and where they sit
with respect to each other,
they are all
a little bit different.
Our closest neighbor is Mars.
So, the reason we go to Mars
is because
we want to understand
ourselves.
Well, what can we learn about
ourselves on Mars
that we can't learn here?
During that
4.6 billion years of violence,
some time we came to
a period of enough quiescence
so that we could begin to cool
on the surface.
And as the planet began to
off gas
its hot interior a little bit
and create water,
and create atmosphere,
we began to mature
as a planet.
Somewhere between that
4.6 billion years
and the 3.8 billion years
to which we can go back,
we got life, but we don't know
exactly when,
and we don't know exactly how.
Our planet is
such a benefit to us in that
its surface keeps
reshaping itself.
The skin basically dives
underneath itself.
And that's good because
that's how we recycle
our materials,
but it is also bad
because the evidence
of our deep past... gone.
Mars on the other hand
hasn't got all that activity
on the surface.
Around 4 billion years ago,
4.1 to 3.9,
it was a really 'bad day'
and I use the term loosely
in our solar system,
another bunch of rogue
planetesimals came crashing
through the inner solar system
slamming into the planets
and you see the evidence today
by all the craters
on the moon, on Mars,
on Mercury.
We can't quite see
through the atmosphere
on Venus very well
and we've got that pesky
ocean-covering on the Earth.
So, a lot of the evidence
on Earth
is... is very cryptic.
But somehow during that time,
we recovered
and we got
this robust biosphere.
Obviously we are all here
tonight reading
the National Geographic,
right?
But not so on Mars.
Mars looks very different
than Earth looks right now.
In that window of time
between 4.6 billion years
and that team of
bandit asteroids
that came through,
was a 400 million year window.
If life formed here then
could it have formed on Mars?
And if it did form on Mars,
where did it go?
Mars, we know had water on it.
The evidence is ample.
Not just water flowing
and shaping,
and weathering
the surface of Mars,
but water standing
in a still pool.
The evidence of which we found
at Yellowknife Bay,
the chemistry of which was
benign enough
that it could've been
habitable for life
from a chemical point of view.
But somewhere between this...
and this, conditions changed.
So, the question is
when did they change
and what happened?
So, we are standing here
at this image,
at Yellowknife Bay.
It looks a lot like
a dried lakebed
and we came to the conclusion
that that's the best model,
for what that environment
was like.
So now,
I'm going to ask you question.
We've got the minerals.
We've got the water.
We did some chemical analyses
and we determined
we have the canonical
six elements
that we deem to be requisite
for life on Earth,
but what else?
What are we not seeing,
that tells us
that an environment
could be habitable or not.
It's like
when you go to buy a house,
what is the owner covering up
that you don't discover
until you've signed
for the mortgage.
But one clue
is the atmosphere.
We are trying to figure out
when the atmosphere got
so thin.
I told you about
the rogue asteroids
coming through.
Unfortunately,
during the time of attack
Mars lost its geo-dynamo...
that is the convection
of metallic stuff
in the interior of the planet
that generates
a magnetic field
like our own protective
magnetic field,
which is really key
for protecting an atmosphere
and preventing it from being
ionized away
by the galactic cosmic rays
and the solar energetic
particles
all of which can do
your atmosphere dirt
until you are left with this
thin little scum of air,
which is what Mars
presently has.
So, I ask you
to think about this.
The chemistry was right,
the minerals were right...
was the atmosphere right?
We don't know.
So, then it tells us
two things.
You gotta have
all the right stuff together
in the right place,
but you also have to
have everything together
at the right time.
So, the evolution
of the environment,
not just in space,
but in time, is key
to determining whether or not
it is a habitable one.
And so Curiosity came to
Gale Crater
to look at a bunch of history
hoping that
one of those layers of rock
might be the Dead Sea Scroll
equivalent on Mars
that would tell us
the secrets
of the evolution
of the Martian surface.
Allow us to get
a little glimpse
into that window of history
that might tell us Mars had
or had not evolved life.
At least we can evaluate Mars
from the perspective of
the most tolerant and
cosmopolitan life on Earth
that would be
the prokaryotic microbes.
And so we measured these rocks
at Gale Crater,
in Yellowknife Bay
and we determined that
the past environment
was probably hospitable
for that type of Earth life.
Check.
Then we took a step further
and we dated that rock.
Now the problem is the
error bars
on an age date are huge.
So, we don't really know with
precision the age,
but we do know
when the rock was exposed.
And we are now proceeding
to do likewise
on other rocks on Mars,
so stay tuned
for more of that.
But the point is,
you've gotta know
what you've got,
where you've got it,
and if it is all together
at the same time
in order to
make a judgment like,
is the environment habitable?
We can't do this alone.
It takes the missions
that came before us.
The Viking, the Pathfinder,
Spirit And Opportunity,
and the orbital assets
that are presently there
to pick out the good spot
and to guide us
as we can pick up and go.
Viking was an amazing mission,
but it couldn't
get up and move to
where the action is.
We could and that's why
we decided
instead of going to
Mount Sharp first,
where all that history reading
awaits,
and we'll get there.
We decided
we needed to take a look first
at promising rock
even in the midst of the lure
of the history
awaiting us on Mount Sharp.
And so we decided
instead of going to
Mount Sharp, to the left,
that we would go to the right,
and check out
these interesting rocks,
these features,
these sedimentary structures
that portended
a right sweet spot in history
when we might have had
a habitable environment
and so we went
to Yellowknife Bay
and I'm not going to describe
the features
of the three different rock
types,
but let me point out that
that's key.
You are not just looking
at one event in time,
you are looking
at a change in time.
We are going across
the horizon,
over the edge of the world
and looking at
three different eras.
When we drilled the hole
there,
we showed that
it was important
to have a human
make a decision,
not to just blindly
make a plan and go there
because
of the sake of the plan.
But to respond to the science
in real time.
Go to where the action is,
go to
where the science story is,
so we are not at the dock
waiting for our ship
to come in,
when it flies into
national airport.
So, we continue to explore.
I love this selfie because
I can't tell you
how amazing it is
to get up every day,
log on
to the latest from Mars,
occasionally catch a glimpse
of our own selves,
and see stuff
that I touched and made,
and it's on Mars!
( laughter )
So, stay with us.
There's more to go.
We've finished
our prime mission.
We've been there
for two years.
It's a very exciting time
and there are
more exciting times ahead.
( applause )
( outro music )